كيف حالك كيف حال عائلتك ، كيف حال
زوجتك أفضل مما أستحق
أه كان هذا صعبًا على كريستينا للحصول
عليه
أه وهو محبط لأنه مرة
أخرى يلعب مثل هذه
الليلة الخاصة
أم حقيقة وخوف أه لدينا الكثير من
الخوف  لأننا لا نمتلك الكثير من
الحقائق
التي تعرفها الليلة الماضية ، كنا نحتفل
بأم ، كيف تبين أنك أكثر
معدية قبل أن تظهر عليك أعراض ،
يا نفس الليلة التي تصاب فيها زوجتي
بفيروس كورونا
17 يومًا في حالتي لدينا
أعراض مختلفة تمامًا ، الحمد لله ،
إنها أقوى مني ، إنها
أقوى مناعة ، ولديها بنية
أقوى وشخصية أقوى ، لكنها فقدت
حاسة
الشم والتذوق ولكن لا يوجد ضغط على الجيوب الأنفية في
رأسها
قليلًا من الخمول وقليل من الخمول
أه إحباط متبقي تجاهي
لأنني تعرف بالتأكيد تقريبًا كيف
مرضت ولكن
هذا هو العامل أه في منحنى التعلم لدينا
والعائلات
تتعامل مع هؤلاء الرجال كما تعلمون في جميع
أنحاء البلاد الآن  لقد حصلت على والدين مريضين
منفصلين في الحجر الصحي ، فإن البطانة الفضية الوحيدة التي
اعتقدت أنها ستكون أنا وهي
يمكن أن نكون معًا ،
لا لماذا مرة أخرى لا نعرف
هذا bs حول الأجسام المضادة وما إذا
كنت
محصنًا أم لا ، سواء كان ذلك أنتوني فوشي أم لا
أي شخص يقوم بذلك سيخبرك
أنه لا يعرف أنني أمتلك أي مناعة
حتى لو كانت لدي الأجسام المضادة وكيف
تعمل
وإلى متى
يجب أن نفصل أنا وزوجتي لمدة أسبوعين آخرين
مما يعني
منزلنا يعتمد على ابنتي بيلا البالغة من العمر 17 عامًا
والتي تصعد
كريس الثاني ، يجب أن أسأل وأنا لا أعرف
الإجابة ولكن فقط بناءً على ما
تقوله ، أنا فقط أعمل على هذا الأمر
في رأسي لذا أنت
و  لقد أثبتت الاختبارات الإيجابية
لكليستينا أن كلاكما يعاني من أعراض
، وربما أفقد شيئًا ما ولكن
لا يمكنك أن تكون معًا الآن ، أعني أنني
أفهم
أنك بحاجة إلى العزلة ،
فستحتاج إلى العزلة ولكن إذا كنت  كلاهما
لديه لماذا لا يمكنك
لماذا لا يمكنك الدخول  الآن حسنًا ،
أنا لست طبيبًا ، لكن هذا ما
تعلمته
أنك تعرف أنني أحبك ، لكنني بقيت في
نزل للعطلات الليلة الماضية وكان لدي
هلاوسان لأنني كنت
جراح دماغ ،
فإليك ما يقولون  إنهم لا
يعرفون
، وفي ظل الحذر
الشديد ، يمكن أن أصابهم مرة أخرى ،
إنهم يريدون منا أن نبقى منفصلين ،
ولدينا أعراض مختلفة تمامًا
والتي تعد مرة أخرى جزءًا من الغرابة
التي تعتقد كريستينا الآن أن
اثنين منهم على الأقل قد أصيبوا بها
في الأشهر القليلة الماضية ، لماذا لا نعرف جيدًا
ولكن خمول حمى الجيوب الأنفية طويلة الأمد بشكل غير
معتاد ، أعتقد أننا سنتعلم
أن فيروس كورونا كان في هذا
البلد
منذ أكتوبر مثل أكتوبر أنه كانت هناك
حالات وكما تعلمون يا رفاق
وأنا أسمع طوال الوقت من جميع
أنحاء البلاد عدد الأشخاص الذين تسمعهم
يقولون
أعتقد أنني كنت أمتلك هذا ، وهذا ما
فقدت حاسة الشم وهذا
وذاك وذاك لكنني لم أجرب أبدًا ،
فهذه الحالات تشبه  تكثر في جميع
أنحاء ج
أعتقد بلدنا أن الإحباط هنا هو
أننا
لا نعرف